steve 31 ans porte l'uniforme de
copilote depuis plus de deux ans
certains diront qu'il a réalisé un rêve
oui et aujourd'hui il est en plus chez
lui pour une durée de cinq mois
nous sommes en partance pour au cayenne
l'heure de décollage approche les
passagers sont invités à embarquer steve
a rejoint son poste fait le dernier
briefing avec le commandant
on étudie la route aucune nouvelle fois
et on va tout mettre dans l'ordinateur
de banc qui va nous permettre d'avoir
les routes que vous avez la sueur sur
notre trois systèmes de navigation il
parle technique plan de vol et météo
mais la question est prend t-il la
mesure de sa réussite
c'est l'histoire de beaucoup de jeunes
des antilles guyane qui ont le même pas
encore que moi moi que ya un peu plus de
chance d'être ici sur ce vol aujourd'hui
mais mais voilà c'est une très grande
fierté un très grand bonheur et de faire
le métier qu'on dont on rêve depuis
qu'on est très jeune donc c'est un grand
plaisir oui ce vol accueil 112 passagers
il est 17h30 les conditions météo sont
idéales direction cayenne temps de vol
2h30 21h le boeing 737 800 en provenance
de fort-de-france se pose
ça y est on est arrivé un peu en avance
15 minutes en avance me semble très
content ça s'est bien passé comme ça une
première c'est pas évident mais tout
s'est très bien passé nous sommes
satisfaits
le cockpit ce vol inaugural oblige
l'arrivée est festive passagers et
membres d'équipage sont sollicités par
la presse locale c'est ma deuxième
saison aux antilles la première à
cayenne est très content d'être ici
l'accueil à leur excellent steve est
invité au coin vip à participer aux
festivités
[Applaudissements]
le moment est à la détente
la pause est mérité mais le temps presse
il faut se préparer à repartir à fort de
france c'est le rythme à suivre celui
qu'a choisi steve lui qui s'épanouit
dans cette fonction après des études et
des efforts conséquents
j'ai la chance d'avoir mes parents qui
m'ont soutenu tout au long du trajet
j'ai eu la chance aussi d'avoir les
pilotes antillo guyanais qui ont tracé
la voie et qui nous ont vraiment donné
de grandes chances à nos jeunes qui
arrivent ont derrière eux et aussi des
pouvoirs publics qui aide les jeunes qui
courent à la jeunesse martinique c'est
qu'on lâche des autres maires et c'est
grâce à tout ça que j'ai plus
aujourd'hui arrivé à faire ce que j'ai
fait bien sûr avec du travail personnel
en fonte steve regarder passer les
avions avec plaisir aujourd'hui hélas
pire en prendre les commandes